all right cookie yes cookie jar my
cookie jar cookie uh where you from
originally um I was born in Salt Lake
City Utah um but I lived the majority of
my life in Southern
California and tell me about your family
um I have Mom and Dad um they're
divorced now um but they are the two
like most loving parents I could have
ever wished for good childhood amazing
childhood um I I loved my parents uh
well I love my parents that's great um
yeah growing up my dad had his own
business and so um watching him just
work super hard was something that um
inspired me to hopefully one day own my
own business and do my own thing um I
just didn't know exactly what it would
be never in a million years would I
think it would be only fans or anything
in sex were there things that you wanted
to do or um I didn't really know what I
wanted to do um so I went to college
just to kind of get on that path because
I was like well I don't know what I want
to do and um Society tells us that we
need to go to school so I went to school
um I ended up getting a job uh straight
out of college doing Tech Consulting up
in the Bay Area um lived there for a few
years worked in Tech and all of that
loved it and it was amazing um then the
pandemic hit and I don't know I just
needed something to do with my time and
my girlfriend at the time was doing only
fans and she was telling me about it and
always wanted me to get into business
with her work with her do whatever and
she kind of showed me a little bit of
the platform and what it did and uh I
was like oh wow this is I've never done
anything like this in my life I've never
sent a nude to anybody in my life so the
thought of doing that scared the crap
out of me so at first I was like no it's
okay like I'm good um um so I kind of
helped more so as like an assistant for
her um just kind of helping her do like
her daily stuff and she would you know
pay me and the more I got involved with
it the more I was like oh it's not porn
but it is porn it was like a weird space
of like I wasn't going to have to like
show up and like [__] a bunch of people
but at the same time like I would be
able to kind of like experiment myself
and find out my own sexuality I'm
inherently not a very sexual person so
like if you were to ask me like what are
your fantasies
like I don't know I'm not really sure to
be honest like I am a huge people
pleaser so like if anything my fantasy
is your fantasy type thing and that kind
of meshed really well with only fans
because here's all of these people these
men in society that you know have
fetishes or um broken marriages um I
even have some fans that have autism um
they're dis disabled and they want to
play out these fetishes or they want to
have some companionship online and
that's what I do best like I am such a
people person I love building
interpersonal Communications with people
I love like people give me life and
doing this was like kind of a way to
explore my sexuality and explore a sexy
side to myself that I never knew that I
had um and I've found out a couple
things along the way like I found out
that I have a fetish who would have
known um you know and just playing into
people's fantasies like learning about
them um you know if somebody came to me
and they were like oh I have this fetish
I really want to like buy a video from
you and you do X Y and Z you know I
would go and research it and I'm like
looking it up like okay what do they do
looking at like porn videos what do they
do when you know they play it out and
then kind of like Gathering what they
the fan wanted and then what a I don't
know the dictionary would explain it as
and then kind of like putting my own
spin on it and making it fun for me and
just like fulfilling people's fantasies
so that's been like a huge just
exploration of myself and um yeah just
if I were to if you would have asked me
five years ago what I was doing today I
sure as [__] would not have said this
and and you're successful at it you're
making money yeah I make really good
money um like I said I was in tech
Consulting um I landed my dream job like
everything I had worked for I I worked
four jobs to put myself through school
like I was a hustler and I got job after
job and it was just shitty after shitty
job where people would move the carrot
and I would be successful and move the
carrot again and so I just kind of got
sick of it and it's hard it's hard being
under some yeah and and and there's just
no promise like I would kill myself at
work I would hit all of the Milestones I
would do everything but then they'd be
like oh well you know we're going to
change this hoping for a raise hoping
for a promotion and even when I got a
promotion I got a race it was like oh
here's a couple ,000 extra I'm like what
am I supposed to do with this like
that's not even a title change and then
you give me like $2,000 extra a year
great love that for me but like it was
never it was just never enough and even
when I had a career you know that was on
a great path I was always doing things
on the side like nanning or working like
um like bars things like that just to
earn money cuz I just am so driven and I
need to have a million things going on
um and again I've always wanted to do my
own business I just again never thought
it would be this like I'm a competitive
bodybuilder so I always thought maybe it
was going to be Fitness but again
there's little money potentially in in
Fitness so um I really just do it for my
own mental sanity and I really didn't
want to muddy those Waters of what was
like my emotional out or my physical and
emotional outlet and then business um
but yeah so just like moving moving the
car it constantly and constantly I was
just sick of it and you know the more
hours I put into my work now the more
money I make and it's synergistically
this is not an easy job oh my God no
like tell me tell me about how much time
and go it's it's so annoying because
there's so many people on the internet
that are just like oh go get a real job
like when only fans was pulling out of
porn right everyone was like oh
everyone's going to have to all those
girls are going to have to go get real
jobs it's like no I wake up and hustle
all day long 365 days out of the year 7
days a week I don't get time off like if
I get if I take time off I don't make
money right if I'm not online if I'm not
talking to my fans if I'm not offline
filming if I'm not posting on social
media if I'm not networking if I'm not
putting myself out there like I don't
make money how many hours a day do you
spend doing some form of that I would
say on a low end
probably
10 to 12 a day a day in the beginning I
was easily working 16 hours a day like
non-stop Around the Clock it was so
exhausting and then the stress of it all
is like I could wake up tomorrow and
it's gone I have no power over that and
that stress alone drives me insane it's
what keeps me up at night because I know
it can be gone tomorrow only fans can
like they tried to do it right they
tried to get out of porn they said we're
we're we're pulling out and I remember I
was in Hawaii uh finalizing my wedding
plans
and oh my God like it was just the worst
week of my entire life I would go out
and do my meetings and then I'd come
back and I was like looking on every
platform like what where are we going
what are we doing I need to make sure
that I have my my app my cookie jar
needs to be on every platform needs to
be taken that way nobody's going to
impers do you have a backup platform now
um I do a little bit on fley just
because um it doesn't make me nearly as
much money as only fans does um but if
that should happen again I I'll have
something to fall back on I I'll at
least have a foundation to to go off of
um but yeah so just that amount of
stress right like let's say I
accidentally sent out a video to a fan
and for whatever reason like one person
wasn't tagged right and I get a
violation or I posted something about
stepsister something I did a video with
a stepsister um and that was like the
theme of the video and that was okay 6
months ago but now it's not okay I'll
get a violation for that and then that
counts towards essentially getting my
account deleted which like back then
wasn't a rule but now it is and so that
amount of like stress of just feeling
like helpless almost is so stressful to
deal with so right now I'm just trying
to focus hustle get as much money as I
can while I can and get the [__] out so
you you were never a sex worker before
this or stripper or anything like that
no never never like I said I've never
even sent a nude to anybody in my life
you're Bas you're basically a girl next
door that's just doing this yeah
and honestly learning how to do it and
talk and take sexy pictures I can still
remember this the first video I ever
took was during Co I put my camera on a
tripod I turned it on I had it facing me
and I just tried to what I thought was
like move sexily and like talk dirty to
the camera I just remember crying
because I was just made me cringe so
hard it just made me feel so unsexy and
I was like oh my gosh I am not made for
this I was not made for this and luckily
my husband was like very supportive he's
like no no no it's okay we'll work on it
we'll do this like I'll I'll coach you
through some things like try this you
know he would take you're married I am
married and and he supports you doing
this oh my gosh yeah he was the one who
was like we should do this like this is
going to be such a great like he called
it what did he say he said it's the Gold
Rush of our of our era and if we would
be stupid not to try in some ways he's
right yes oh my gosh yes I I left my
dream job doing Tech Consulting because
I
made three times what I would make in a
single month there and I was like why am
I doing this why am I killing myself and
I'm sure it's increased since then yes
definitely oh yeah definitely what what
are the downsides of this there's got to
be a downside to
everything the downside
is it sounds weird but I'm extremely
lonely um I went from working in a tech
Consulting where I was constantly on
meetings constantly talking to people
constantly in team meetings group
meetings one-on ones whatever it was in
this collaborative environment of tons
of people that were hustling and
bustling and grinding and hey let's go
out to lunch or hey let's go grab coffee
let's go out to happy hour afterwards
let's have a holiday party right to I'm
by myself in solitude all day and
thankfully I have amazing fans who are
just such kind
people like a lot of people think I
think a lot of people think that these
fans are there's something wrong with
them or they bunch of creeps yeah like
creepy or they don't respect women or
you know and and don't get me wrong I'm
sure there's definitely some out there
but all my fans know I'm married and
they love that they're always asking
where's where's your husband where's
your where is he what is he doing how is
he see in the video sometimes oh all the
time yeah we film together all the time
I mean I I do live streams all the time
too and they love when he comes on the
live cuz he'll just come on and we'll
play some games um we'll do like live
[__] for my fans and they just they
love it they just love seeing like our
intimacy together and there's so many
fans that will ask for like custom
videos of just us like I just want to
see you guys super intimate and super
passionate like that intimacy between
the two of us captured on camera how
does
doing having your intimacy be part of
your income change your relationship
with him yeah there's definitely in the
beginning every time we would have sex
or every time we do anything intimate
there was a camera there's our phone our
camera our phone our camera our phone
and so because in our head we were like
well if we record this we can make money
if we record this we can make money and
him and I are very intimate we have sex
very frequently even before only fans
that was that's just like our how we
connect with each other really deeply so
putting money in it was a little bit
difficult in the beginning we definitely
had to set some boundaries of how long
how long have you been married um we've
been married 2 years now but we've been
together for 10 years um so yeah it was
just and does he help you with the
business or is that is is that all he
does he helps a lot um he actually came
home one day with an A7 Sony camera like
a professional camera and he's like
we're going to use this like what is
that he's like I don't know I don't know
how to use it but I'm going to learn
he's your cameraman kind of he is he is
my cameraman he is my business partner
we go go on walks sometimes in the
evening and I'm just like I'm just
struggling I you know I'm not hitting
the markers that I want I need to help
with marketing um he read a whole
marketing book Because neither one of us
are marketers um he how do you how do
you Market this social media like on
Twitter Instagram um I'm starting a
YouTube channel like any place I can get
my foot in the door somewhere that's not
going to ban me I'm there and even if I
am going to get banned I have backups
for days TI talk you got like five
backups um same with
Instagram um the Chive the fet life uh
you name it I probably have an account
somewhere with some sort of content out
there um trying to just Market myself
what what about the stigma of being a
basically your porn actress yeah you
know what's funny is I think that it's
becoming more pop culture today that
it's more socially acceptable at first I
used not tell people what I did I was oh
it was social media like social media
being an only fans girl is so much it
doesn't sound as horrible as like you
could tell your mother that your
grandmother that yeah than uh than
saying I'm a porn actress yeah for sure
and I I think in today's society it's
changing um again I used to tell people
that I was in social media but today um
you're in social media yeah social media
I feel I feel like that's every only
fans girl's like cover story it's like
Oh I'm a social media influencer or
whatever um but I I do remember the day
I told my parents because again I have
great relationship with my parents I
call my mom almost every day I call my
dad multiple times a week like how how
did you tell them this um I just was on
FaceTime with my mom and I said Mom I
have an only fans and she just
goes okay and now it's funny she
actually helps me um so she helps run um
my accounting so I am not I am dyslexic
so I'm super bad with numbers your
parents think no oh I mean from day one
they they didn't have any like negative
emotions or feelings towards it at all
it was more so just like
okay okay all right cool sounds great
like what is it like let's they knew
about it because of my friends there's
something like I don't know anything
about only the fans but I can just tell
you as somebody that's hearing your
story the fact that you do it with your
husband kind of makes it somewhat
acceptable or wholesome or whatever yeah
and I definitely think that there's it's
funny because I was I was afraid at
first to tell my fans that I was married
because I was like well the whole alure
is that I'm supposed to be obtainable
that they can reach out to me and talk
to me and you know confide in me but I
feel like when you're your authentic
self on the internet that's what
attracts your people right pretending to
be something you're not is not going to
get you fans like it may for a little
bit but that's so
exhausting to upkeep
um that I just I didn't want to do that
from the get-go I don't I don't want to
tell people that I'm I'm not married
because my fans all know that they need
to respect him right there's no like
cucking situation going on like we can
definitely play into some fantasies some
fetishes but you better be sure as [__]
you know that like my husband is my
husband and that comes first and they
all respect that and they love that and
in all honesty I feel like a lot of men
see me and my husband have a very
successful marriage do we have ups and
downs absolutely what marriage doesn't
but at the same time like we can
communicate and learn together and grow
together um through all of those
challenges and my fans can see that and
because of that a lot of them have these
failed marriages where they have they
tell me they haven't slept with their
wife in months you know and it's almost
like a sex therapist where like I'm
talking to them and I'm like well do you
talk to her about what she likes have
you tried to talk to her about like
what's happening this or that and a lot
of them you know have come back to me
and been like you were so right like I
talked to my wife and now things are
great you know or something like that
and I love that like one of my my most
loyal fans I remember he told me that he
got a girlfriend and I was like kind of
sad for me because I was just like I
don't know how your girlfriend's going
to feel about it but he is just such a
sweet human being and I just absolutely
adore him and when he told me that he
got a girlfriend I was sad but I was
like I'm sad for me but I'm so happy for
you and then the other day he messaged
me and he's like guess what my
girlfriend says she's okay with me
having an only fans and I was like oh my
gosh I love this for us we could be like
a little thruple here I'm like bring her
in like let's have some fun together and
like all of that and uh you know he's
he's like we we'll start slow but like
maybe one day we could all do like um
like a video call together and like have
some sexy fun on a video call or
something like that so the fact that
you're married kind of makes it again it
makes it more safe it makes it safe
because yeah U you're not a threat I and
I think that that's what a lot of people
think that this is more than what it is
it's fun sexy online
companionship um do you guys want to pay
for like girlfriend experience and they
want to have that attention sure but
that's just because they're probably
super lonely when you're at a party with
your friends though do they are they
like they Whispering behind your back oh
she's only fans oh my God no like if
anything all of my fans and or my
friends are super supportive of it and I
I
learned years ago that pretending to be
anything other than my true authentic
self doesn't get me anywhere and it
doesn't get me real friends
um so I've just never been anything less
than authentic with my friend group and
if you don't like my LIF style and you
don't like me as a person because of the
choices that I make like pot and Kettle
man like I don't judge you for what you
do you don't get to judge me for what I
do um and because of that I have the
most supportive friends the most amazing
friends I just know like even when I'm
having issues with business or you know
relationship stuff or anything that
makes it complicated because of what I
do for a living they're always there
like they never say oh well you do sex
like sex um work for a living so of
course you're going to have these issues
never once has that ever been like a
point of discussion
ever it's it's important I think in your
case to have a partner who's supportive
of this he he approves of it absolutely
if anything a lot of husbands would be
like [__] no exactly and and that just
speaks for like how secure he is in
himself right he knows like I'm not
going to leave him for some random guy
online CU he gives me money like
absolutely he proba enjoys the fact that
a million guys love you yeah oh my gosh
yeah he loves it so we actually met at a
rave and and I was in nipple pasties and
this is how much of like a nons [__] I
was before I had never had a one night
stand in my life until I met him out of
Rave and I was like he's pretty hot and
then he saw me in the nipple pasties he
was like she's pretty hot and then you
know we have a one night stand and then
we've been together ever since he's a
handsome guy he is
handsome um so so you you you see doing
this how long how old are you 29 29 and
you could do this for another I could do
this
forever I could I I feel like so many
people in society it's funny that you
ask me my age I've actually never
disclosed my age to anybody not that I'm
ashamed of it because I love my age I
think I look great for my age I think 29
is still young as [__] so I don't know
why everybody is so afraid of it but I
just it didn't ever feel like it
benefited me to let people know my age
it doesn't matter how old I am you're
here for me why does my age matter right
and if you want to play into a fantasy
great as long as everything's consensual
and legal that sounds great to me you
want me to be 25 amazing you want me to
be 19 great you want me to be 46 cool
let's play into it right like that's the
whole thing it's like it's a fantasy so
my age who cares it doesn't matter do
you enjoy the freedom I do that is
definitely no one's going to you don't
have a boss I don't I don't have a boss
I do have a higher power which is only
fans and their I don't even know their
team of but they're probably not going
to pull that again yeah let's let's hope
so um but yeah that that was one of the
main things that I
loved doing this was I have always said
if I'm at work and I finish all my work
by 3: I'm going to go the [__] home and
if you have a problem with that that's
on you right my work's done you want me
to sit here like first off I'm being
paid salary so whether I'm here 8 hours
or 12 hours it really doesn't matter as
long as all my shit's done I'm hitting
all my markers I was actually exceeding
all my markers so Friday comes around
300 p.m. yeah I'm going to go home but I
always had those bosses that at like
8:50 they were walking around checking
who was sitting in their desk and at :10
like 510 or 50:5 they were walking
around seeing who was still in the
office it's like I don't want that kind
of pressure because the more I work the
more money you make not the other way
around and so with this just being able
to have the freedom to do whatever
travel like meet amazing people the most
amazing friends I have ever met in my
life are in this industry and it sounds
weird but there's something about
meeting a complete stranger having a
semi regular Conversation Over messages
maybe a FaceTime call then they show up
and you get naked together and you're
like okay let's shoot a video and you
just become like best friends like
there's it just takes away all of the
societal you get sexual with other
people other people yeah we've filmed
with other people before I filmed with
other girls um we filmed with other
couples before and they just become our
best freaking friends um because there's
such a level of trust and respect for
each other and at the end of the day we
know this it's just business so you're
you're trading partners sometimes
sometimes we have um not full swaps but
soft swapping um and so you talked this
out with the other couple absolutely oh
yeah and and it's never like we show up
and like that's step one like that's
it's never like that it's with people
we've established a really really
long-standing friendship with uh we talk
about boundaries we most of the time if
like let's say it's another couple um
they'll come over and the girl and I
will shoot that way you know we can
check our chemistry and then we'll do
parallel and we'll do parallel for a
while until we get more comfortable we
feel like we can trust them we talk
about boundaries very slow steps and
even then it's just soft swapping
between the two of the couples um what
is soft swapping uh hands and mouths
essentially got it just oral fingering
[__] that kind of stuff yeah and
then respective Partners [__] the
respective
wife um you know maybe we'll cross those
boundaries one day but it's just one of
those things
where this is my mar marriage right and
I take that very seriously he takes it
very seriously and we always want to
make sure like we are the priority not
work not making each other uncomfortable
right like I'm sure a lot of people will
go out on the internet and look at
Twitter or whatever and see all these
people having these origies and that's
great for them I feel no pressure to do
that for myself and what's funny is that
even when we were collabing a lot with
other creators I never really made that
much more money by those videos because
my fans really want to know who that
person is and I think that's a
reflection of who I am as a person
because I really want to get to know you
like I ask every one of my fans what's
the name I can call you whether it's
your real name or a nickname like I want
to respect people's privacy but I really
want to get to know you I want to know
are you married do you have kids what do
you do for a living how was your day
like genuinely ask I remember there was
one week that I I sent a couple of my
top fans just like little audio notes
saying you know happy Friday you know I
hope you have an amazing day and I hope
to talk to you soon and like so many
guys were just like I've never received
something like that like I genuinely
care about my fans and that's why I'm
very cautious of who I collab with to
because if you're a [__] person I don't
want to send my fans to you because I
know you're not going to take care of
them like these are people who I build
relationships with and I and I really
value those right like I have like I
said guys that have disabilities guys
that are autistic and this is the only
form of relationship they can have like
I hold that
so to such a high standard that I don't
want to collab with you if you're going
to treat them like [__] and you're just
going to try and like drain them and
kick them to the curb like that's not
what this is about um and then again
with you know us collabing with other
people or me collabing with other girls
I never made that much more money by
selling those videos because my fans
like okay cool you had sex with a person
great I love that for you but that was
it but when I have them on my live
streams and they get to see their
personality and they get to see us
interact and they get to see like our
friendship that we're like actually
friends like they freaking go crazy they
just on my my live streams I swear it's
like if you were to walk into your local
dive bar at like a small town all the
guys are like oh hey John hey hey Dan
how are you you know they they've like
asked what's up man like they're buying
each other raffle tickets from my
panties they're like giving each other
prize gifts because he won the panties
two weeks ago and this guy's never won
panties so he's giving him prizes I was
like what is happening here but it's
just like such a wholesome experience
like that's why I love going live I go
live at least once a week but just
having that little like group where we
all get together on a Wednesday night
we're just like everybody grab a beer
and let's all hang out together they
love it it's like what what advice would
you give to a woman who's thinking about
considering doing something like
this the advice I would give to somebody
who's starting first off would would you
advise
I have I have mentored people um I tell
people like if you had a younger sister
would you say you should I do have I
have two younger sisters would you would
you want them to do it if they truly
wanted to absolutely um but I want to
tell that like it's not rainbows and
butterflies it's not like so many girls
come to me and they're like oh I just
want to take some pictures of my feet
and sell my panties on the internet well
reality check sweetie no one gives a
[__] because you're a dime dozen you
have to distinguish yourself you have to
grind it is not easy I've mentored
probably about 50 women who were excited
about starting and all all but one was
successful and by successful I mean
making you know I mean when you say all
but one only one out of one out of 50 in
my opinion what I would call successful
that I actually mentored um and for
every girl that's successful and only
fans there's probably there's there's a
million that fail that's what there's a
percentage that re rank that ranks based
off of income um and if you look there's
there's a reason why girls are 0.01 like
I think I did the math and out of all
the creators my percentage ranking there
was like less than a thousand of girls
who were making what I make and there's
millions of people on only fans like
it's you're doing very well yes I am
doing very well and I'm I'm super
blessed for that and you know I've I've
seen friends that have made more money
than me and have been the most unhappy
people because they're missing something
so I try to stay so unbelievably
grateful for what I'm doing and for the
opportunity that I have and just staying
super present in that moment because I
don't want
to forget how act absolutely lucky I am
right there's always luck that plays
into this right there's hard work but
there there is some luck
and I have my dad lost his job um when
we were a kid and so I know what it's
like to be uh poor to almost lose your
house to be hungry and that's why I'm
doing this too is my my both my parents
they don't have like a life savings that
business went under in 2008 when the
housing market popped and that was their
livelihood that was their savings that
was their
f1k and in all honesty they're the
reason why I absolutely kill myself
every single day are you helping your
your parents I help my mom with um her
uh accounting that she helps me with so
I pay her for that um and you know
obviously if they my parents are never
going to ask me for anything um and
they're just such selfless people that
they would never even accept money from
me like that even if they needed it they
have always figured it out but I'm like
I'm thinking about the long term for
them like me and my husband same with
his parents they don't have a lot of
money either we want to buy like a
little um quadruple
so that all four of them can live in it
and like that's our end goal is to just
be able to afford to buy each of them a
house a nice idea it would be awesome
they're all best friends too even though
like all four of them are divorced my
parents his parents but like I still
have Christmas with my mom and dad you
know like they're best friends like
we're in a family group chat together we
all FaceTime together like we're like um
excuse me my husband calls my family uh
the Disney Channel family cuz we're just
so like lovey and touchy feely and uh
his parents same thing they live less
than a mile away from each other and
we're always spending time
together it's wonderful you've carved
out a really nice life for yourself with
a lot of hard work yeah definitely and
your right timing you know this couldn't
have been done 10 years ago or no
probably five years ago right uh and
again that's why I say if anyone asked
me 5 years ago what I would be doing
today definitely sex work was not even
on my radar at all um and that was
probably one of the hardest decisions I
ever made was deciding to leave my dream
job I landed it it was amazing I got
paid more money than I ever thought I
would make uh the company was pre-ipo so
I was I was set like I was going to make
it big with them and I was so un
unbelievably
grateful but when I looked at it it was
this is now or never this is the time to
take a risk while I'm young while I can
afford to my my husband has a steady job
so even if this failed I could figure it
out so again super blessed and lucky
that he has that support for me that I
can go out and be a bit more risky
um but it paid off and I wouldn't change
that for a
second all right cookie jar thank you so
much for sharing your story I think this
is probably almost like an endorsement
for only fans isn't it yeah
hopefully I'm not sure where I stand on
that but
you know you seem to be happy and
healthy and you guys seem like a great
couple so yeah we are we're super happy
and super blessed and I I just couldn't
be more grateful I'm happy for you thank
you all right thank
you